It's a legalistic religion. It's not
mystical in any way shape or form.
According to Islam, every action a human
can engage in is categorized as either
forbidden, uh disliked, meaning you you
shouldn't do it, it's not necessarily
you're going to go to hell for it, but
neutral, okay, whatever,
uh recommended, we'd like you to do it,
but you don't have to do it, and um
obligatory, all right? Every single
action in this life. It's a very
totalitarian system. That's what Sharia
is, and if I forget, we really need to
talk about Sharia, because it's in the
news, and there's some input I'd like to
say about that. But,
now, if you look at the religion,
some of the stuff that we like to call
radical or try to present as aberrants
amongst Muslims is actually 100%
mainstream, all right? Um This can't be
possible. No, no, it well, it it is
possible, but we'll get into the with
the moderate.
>> go to Dubai, and they they can
go out with my wife, We'll address We'll
address that.
>> go to Iran, and someone's hair showing,
and they get the crap beat out of them.
>> I cannot reconcile these two Muslim
worlds. Patience. Okay, boss. [laughter]
Okay. Okay, hold on. Yeah, yeah, no,
because this is this Let me just really
Because this is
Because it Yeah, yeah, this is a thorny
issue.
Okay, so, the religion, Sunni mainstream
Islam. Okay, for example, it allows
polygamy. That's not That's not open to
debate. Okay. The Quran talks about how
you can, you know, punish your wife by
beating her. Yes. Okay. Number two.
Concubinage, right? Sex slaves. This is
in the Quran. Yeah. And it's important,
okay, real quick segway, because you
mentioned while, you know, the the
Bible, the Old Testament, and
>> comeback. [clears throat]
>> And they do that, and Christians have
risen above it. Okay, here's a
difference. It's a very interesting
difference. I wrote about this like 20
years ago. If you look at the old Let's
say Let's stick with the Old Testament,
because that's what they talk about.
>> Yeah. Um Slavery, and all of that.
>> slavery, war, genocide, Joshua, all that
sort of thing,
as it's presented. If you look at the
actual text, the way it's written, okay,
so, God commands Joshua and, you know,
the Israelites or the Hebrews to go to
war and he mentions the names of the
people, the Jebusites, the Hivites,
that's the you know, and the Canaanites,
etc. etc. And the language is very
temporal. It's it's uh it's finite. It
it's not open-ended. It's it's almost in
the past tense, you know, they fought
them and that was it.
Now, if you go to the Quran, okay, and
guess what? Even though their enemies
were actually um identifiable personages
throughout history, the Persians, the
Rastrians, the Christian Byzantines, and
so forth, it doesn't use that word. It
uses uh the generally the word the
kafir, which can be translated as
infidel or mushrik, okay? Like there's a
lot of words. And the language is when
you read the Quran, it's in the present
tense, okay? So, fight
the people uh fight the kafir, fight the
people of the book, Christians and Jews,
fight. It's it's a constant um
open-ended commandment. Whereas the Old
Testament, it's recording a historical
account. God said to them, fight that
group of people in that group that area
at that point in time. So, it never got
codified into some sort of a vision for
Jews or Christians that you have to be
at war with everyone.
The Quran's a very different. The
language is is very transcendent and
above and beyond the finite moment. And
so, it got codified there that that's
what Sharia law is. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back
In the righteous